alors jacques bravo d'abord dans l'est
dans les années 60 à l'époque où tout le
monde avait les douilles jusque-là
contestation et tout soit et estrades
costard gris n'avait pas de conscience
politique à l'époque tout le monde avait
une conscience politique sa manette
patois pas du tout et j'en ai encore
mois maintenant d'ailleurs j'ai super
schiphol savoir que personne n'a perçu
que tu t'es jamais exprimé là dessus
s'est jamais fait part de ses opinions
politiques
j'en ai pas vraiment c'est pour ça et
quand quand françoise prend
officiellement des positions politiques
qui ne sont pas celles qu'il est convenu
de d'affiché dans le dans le métier dans
le show-business sa jane ça te fait
marine tu t'en fous chez moi je me rue
mais je l'imaginé c'est que c'est qu'on
lui ait prêté ses propos comme ça parce
qu'elle a dit enfin on a pris une phrase
d'un truc comme l'un des trucs habituels
prend le petit mot qu'il faut pour en
faire le titre alors que c'est pas du
tout ça est ce que tu crois qu'on est
réellement informé qu'on sait pas la
moitié de ce qui se passe oui c'est
alors là j'en suis à persuader il était
persuadé qu'on nous cache tout on nous
dit rien absolument
le coup d'état en urss par exemple il ya
cru toi je sais même pas de quoi tu
parles alors donc jamais tu ces gars
je peux encore battsek avait enfermé
dans tout ce qui s'enseigne oui mais je
sais que gorbatchev est allé chez
mitterrand il a dormi dans l'hydrogène
ça doit être dur chambre ils ont pas le
même pour personne en tard le livre de
gorbatchev était au courant de quoi le
livre de gorbatchev où il n'y a pas la
même chose dans la version russe
anglaise et française est au courant de
ça non mais c'est ça permet de vendre
dans les trois pays
là oui c'est des versions différentes
ils ont essayé de se réconcilier à
latché tu que tu vas voir regarde le
magazine du faux